[Music]
hallelu shangela halleloo
how you doing it's miss Rona ruining all
the fun or what oh I told 2020 she will
never be glamour honey never I have to
say shangela though I mean it's a very
serious thing that is happening right
now
with a covet 19 however your videos your
instagrams and your tic TOCs
I love that we are still trying to find
the humor in the situation because it is
such a dark time for so many but I do
think it is important that we continue
to laugh
Korona you're not taking my love when I
come out of quarantine this space will
be so hydrated this skin will be so
moisturized this hair will be so deeply
conditioned you can smell the whole ova
from down the street is it important for
you and your fans to kind of keep the
laughter going definitely seen it it's
just you know I never want to make full
light of the situation because
coronavirus is very real and it's
affecting so many people around the
world I'm trying to definitely balance
you know being there for my fans and and
supporting messages about you know
washing your hands and social distancing
and all that with also us finding humor
in life and still maintaining our
ability to smile and have optimism and
have hope I love it so thank you for
that because those keep me laughing and
I really appreciate that um something
else that I'm very excited for is your
new show on HBO we're here drag is about
empowerment we travel across this
country to take people from who they are
to what they can be thank God I brought
these
we're actually taking someone local
turning them into fierce drag queen
shangela laughs the drag queen and
Eureka this is gonna be I mean I can't
think of three better drag queens to be
on this show why was this a show that
you felt so passionately about well
first of all is thrilled to be able to
work with Queens who I know are very
hardworking and creative and
professional people like Bob the drag
queen in Eureka we have a lot of fun
together
and what kind of like three sisters that
got kind of you know man you get yeah
came up as a beautiful mashup so I'm
having a great time and the show is
gonna be so powerful impactful when they
rough idea to me I was like yeah because
this show is going across America
specifically to small towns in America
where people don't always occur cute
community that they have a voice or a
community around them of people who
support them they think like them have
similar experiences or at least show
love so that's what we're doing we're
showing up in these places and not only
connect with these people in their
stories and do they have some very very
interesting stories everything about me
I won't when another has been used it
all started when Haley came out my mom
had this look cause she thought I would
go to help if you could say something to
them now what would you say you know
when you do go to these smaller towns
and smaller cities what does it feel
like to kind of break down that barrier
of what people think
members of the lgbtq+ community well it
definitely is a shock at first when I go
into somebody's plate because it feels
like I'm going back in time to my
childhood do my coming-out moment you
know and growing up in a small town so I
really identify a lot with the people
that we've been working with and really
connecting with in these clique that's
the first thing second thing I did I
after the shock I get really excited
because I'm like in my town we never had
this
we never had a drag show when I was
growing up so to be able to produce one
that is upon high quality one and work
with these people that come out of their
shells and showcase you know you do have
the confidence and not only death let's
see how many people we can get to come
out and show you that there is a
complete love you I'm not a fairy
godmother but watch when I think of drag
queens I think shangela is at the top of
my list and there's a few reasons for
that you are an incredible performer and
you really support the lgbtq+ community
and that is really important to you I've
cried so much in filming this show and
you know I'm not a big crier you don't
you'll see it gooey fish all the time I
had that one T on all-stars three and
that's bad yet so so you don't see them
excuse me with them it is like I feel
like they are my real children I have to
ask you right now because I appreciate
shangela is opinion with Drag Race
Season 12 yes I have been watching
Gregory you know I'm from the family
it's like being able to connect with
these girls I feel like so close to even
though I don't know a lot of them yet
okay but give me that Tina shangela T
who are you rooting for on season 12
okay we don't we have episode what three
or four it's anybody's game
to me because you never know who's gonna
be the dark horse and come from the back
and be like BAM
but you know some people that Bret
definitely stand out to me so far
gg-good has been doing an amazing job
and and it's funny for me to watch
because a lot of these contestants this
year seem so young they seem like you
know they were 11 when I was on season
three in that environment of drag race
I'm Aidan I feel like is being bullied a
bit you know some of these other Queens
aren't being so nice we all remember
note gate you know gave is that
why will people call it so we got no gay
tool get me sugar daddy gay I had so
many hey this is this shade shangela and
it's my name crossed out I didn't show
shoe cuz I thought it was not come
forward appropriate but you decide to
hang it on the wall the perspective that
I watched from is from a girl that's
been there three 1722 right oh my
perspective is gonna be a lot different
than a lot of fans who watch the show
and watch it as a pant which I also
consider myself a fan of the show but
you gotta understand up in there in that
workroom I know how being on that tank
can throw you completely I remember
watching the show back after season 3
and seeing a lot of things about myself
that I was like okay I see where I could
have been wrong in that moment where at
the moment you don't see that okay so
I'm actually super forgiving to a lot of
girls and temper tantrums and fights and
all that leave the competition of it all
I don't really get into that too much
because I know that in the in that
competition you wanted it so badly
sometimes you lose yourself
congratulations on we're here like I
said I can't wait to watch shows even
it's exactly I think what the world
needs right now and I hope that we're
able to bring some type of of extra love
and compassion to what's going on in the
world right now but I just continue to
vibe there but it's a social distance
wash your hands and think of others I
love you thank you bad love you too hope
to see you out on the road soon when we
get out of quarantine but I'm coming up
out this bunker like Kimmy Schmidt I'm
gonna be like